in the chaos of the last few months I've
put a lot of things on hold
not just the blog also my writing and
since those two things sort of go hand
in hand I want to start both up at the
same time so I started work on a third
book which I'm really excited about hard
sci-fi I've also started a new tumblr
called 52 books 52 weeks in which it's
exactly what it sounds like the idea is
that the people I work with are way more
knowledgeable than me so this is how you
know I will destroy them I feel I've got
an intent link in the doobly I've also
started work on a new album what'd you
make music yes but you already knew that
it's simple and unprofessional music but
it makes me really happy and creative
and I'll put it on soundcloud when it's
so now you might be saying nerdwriter
you have a job now aren't you putting
too many things on your plate to which
you know I can only say yes I don't know
I figure what's the use of having an
appropriately full plate on the back I
just press the red buckin at me
recording yeah yeah a real smile okay
one more time ready Shelley are you
doing it no it's videoing now you're
videoing ready
cool Willy hey ready